an indiscriminate war
kirill's just 18 months old
doctors battle to save him
agony for his mother and stepfather as
they wait
but there's nothing the medics can do
devastation
why couldn't they save him his mother
cries
the toddler was killed on friday as
russian forces bombarded the southern
city of mariopol
others also wounded
a humanitarian corridor was meant to be
opened here today and in the nearby city
of volnovaka
but a limited ceasefire never held
the man who unleashed the invasion now
playing the victim after western allies
punished russia in response with
unprecedented economic sanctions
these are methods of fighting against
russia these uh
sanctions that you can see uh
equivalent of war
but thankfully it has not come to an
actual war
but we understand what what
what
these
threats
are about
but it's vladimir putin's forces making
the menacing moves
these images from russia's defense
ministry show troops outside kiev
and attacking from the air
it's a military threat that was meant to
halt briefly in parts of southern
ukraine to allow civilians safe passage
out of harm's way
but the effort had to be halted
humanitarian corridors must work today
mariopol and volnovaka to save people
women children the elderly to give food
and medicine to those who remain
a russian attack on a nuclear plant this
week underlining how the violence in
ukraine can't necessarily be contained
within its borders
are all those who hesitate now
whether is the necessary to close the
sky over ukraine
ready to sacrifice the leaves and health
not only of ukrainians but also of their
children
this is not about a war somewhere far
away in ukraine it's about your safety
and about the nuclear danger to the
whole world but nato allies have ruled
out imposing a no-fly zone it would
require them to shoot down russian
planes risking a much wider war
instead countries are individually
sending in weapons
helping ukraine to defend its own
airspace
here ukrainian forces apparently downing
a russian helicopter
civilians too are taking a stand
this is the southern city of person the
first to fall to russian troops but not
going quietly
[Applause]
debrahing sky news level